what a joke
even now
as the latest merely mouthed apology
stumbles out of one side of his mouth
a new set of deflections and distortions
pour from the other yeah
but the damage is already done
the public have made up their mind
they don't believe a word the prime
minister says
they know what he is
as ever with this prime minister those
close to him find themselves ruined and
the institutions he vows to protect
damaged yes
good ministers forced to walk away from
public service
the chancellor's career up in flames
and the leader of the scottish
conservatives rendered pathetic
for all those unfamiliar with this prime
minister's career this isn't some
fixable glitch in the system
it's the whole point
it's what he does
it's who he is
he knows he's dishonest and incapable of
changing
so he drags everybody else down with him
the more people debase themselves
parroting
order i can't hear what's being said
because you're making
mr public i'm all right
here's starmap
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't want to talk about breaking
rules do we i don't think that's a good
time to discuss and just say i think he
just withdraws that and works around and
i'm sure that with the knowledge that
he's gained over many many years he can
use appropriate words there is in
keeping with good temperament language
of this house kirsten
mr speaker
i respect that ruling from the chair
the prime minister knows what he is
and so
he drags everyone else down with him the
more people debase themselves parroting
his absurd defenses
the more the public will believe all
politicians are the same all as bad as
each other
and that suits this prime minister just
fine
some members opposite seem oblivious to
the prime minister's game some know what
he's up to
but are too weak to act
but others are gleefully playing the
part the prime minister cast for them
a minister on the radio this morning
saying it's the same as a speeding
ticket
no it's not no one has ever broken down
in tears because they couldn't drive
faster than 20 miles an hour outside a
school don't insult the public with this
nonsense
but mr speaker as it happens
the last minister who got a speeding
ticket and then lied about it ended up
in prison and i know because i
prosecuted him
[Music]
and last week last week we were treated
to a grotesque spectacle one of the
prime minister's loyal supporters
accusing teachers and nurses of drinking
in the staff room during lockdown
[Applause]
members opposites can associate
themselves with that if they want
but those of us
who take pride in our nhs workers our
teachers
and every other key worker who got us
through those dark days will never
forget their contempt
plenty didn't agree with every rule the
prime minister wrote
but they followed them nonetheless
because in this country
we respect others
we put the greater good above narrow
self-interest
and we understand
that the rules apply to all of us
this morning i spoke to john robinson a
constituent of the member for litchfield
i want to tell you his story
when his wife died of covid
john and his family obeyed the prime
minister's rules
he didn't see her in hospital
he didn't hold her hand as she died
their daughters and grandchildren drove
a hundred miles up the motorway
clutching a letter from the funeral
director in case they were questioned by
the police
they didn't have a service in the church
john's son-in-law stayed away
because he would have been the forbidden
seventh mourner
doesn't the prime minister realize
that john
would have given the world to hold his
dying wife's hand
even if it was just for nine minutes
but he didn't
because he followed the prime minister's
rules
rules that we now know the prime
minister blithely repeatedly and
deliberately ignored
after months
of insulting excuses
today's half-hearted apology will never
be enough for john robinson
if the prime minister had any respect
for john
and the millions like him who sacrificed
everything to follow the rules
he'd resign
but he won't
because he doesn't respect john
he doesn't respect the sacrifice of the
british public
he is a man without shame
looking past the member for litchfield
and the nodding dogs in the cabinet
there are many decent honorable members
on the benches opposite
who do respect john robinson
who do respect the british public
they know the damage the prime minister
is doing
they know things can't go on as they are
and they know
it's their responsibility
to bring an end to this shameful chapter
today i urge them once again
don't follow in the slipstream of an out
of touch out of control prime minister
put their conscience first
put their country first
put john robinson first
and remove the prime minister from
office
bring decency honesty and integrity back
into our politics
and stop the denigration of everything
that this country stands for
sir william prime minister mr speaker i
apologize once again uh profusely to to
john robinson to all those
uh who lost loved ones particularly
those uh who suffered during the the
pandemic and mr speaker in my statement
i have uh tried to explain why i spoke
to the house as i did the right
honourable gentleman has chosen to
uh to respond with a a series of uh
personal attacks on me and i understand
why he uh why he does that uh but i
think it and i i understand that mr
speaker but i think it would have been a
good thing
if in the course of his remarks he had
addressed some of the uh issues that i
mentioned uh not least the crisis in
ukraine uh with the impact that that is
having on the livelihoods of everybody
in this country
and it is to address that uh that this
government will get on with our job mr
speaker it is to focus on the needs of
the british people and when he talks
about nodding dogs mr speaker i'd remind
the house that there was a certain
nodding dog who sat nodding oh in the
previous uh labor administer the
previous labour shadow cabinet mr
speaker uh that would happily have
installed uh the right the honourable
member
for islington north and made i think a
disastrous mistake in the security of
our country at a very difficult time
this country this government will get on
with the with the difficult job of
taking us through
the aftershocks of the covid pandemic
leading not just this country but i
think uh the world in our response uh to
the violence that we're seeing in
ukraine uh i i
must say uh that i i renew my apologies
i renew my apologies to to john robinson
to families up and down the land but i
think the best thing that we can do now
for this country as politicians is is
not to indulge in personal abuse of the
kind that we've heard and to get on with
our jobs